I could not wait to get back into the
studio for today's show a partially
because we're off to the best new member
start of the year 213 new members in the
first six days of January so far by far
our best start ever in a new year
partially I couldn't wait to get back in
the studio today because the YouTube
channel despite it being January which
is usually the worst month of the year
is already on track to surpass 2018 by
30% even without any more growth
throughout the year but it wasn't just
self-serving stuff I also couldn't wait
to get back into the studio today
because it was a huge news weekend
starting with the news that Robert
molars from Prussia investigation has
been extended potentially by up to six
additional months now why is this huge
it's huge because Trump and his
defenders have been telling us for more
than a year now that this thing is
almost over for you know forget for a
second that they said it would never get
going right forget for a second that
they said no one would ever be indicted
no one would be convicted no one would
go to prison those ships have already
sailed over the horizon
but remember that starting last
Thanksgiving and that by that I mean
Thanksgiving 2017 okay not 2018 they
were saying
Moeller will be done by Christmas 2017
Muller will be done by January 2018
Muller will be done by summer 2018
Thanksgiving 2018 Christmas 2018 and
then we were told right after the new
year 2019 molars going to be done well
we learned over the weekend that the
molar grand jury has been extended by a
period up to six months meaning the
investigation could go on up to six more
months if not longer now the actual
duration may vary depending on how much
more work there is to do and what I mean
by that is the grand jury was initially
18 months it's now been extended for up
to a six month period if Moeller just
needs another month then this would just
cover that additional month and then it
could end but whatever the time is this
has been extended and we should expect
many more indictments be
it is the extension of a grand jury
indictments of course so far include
Michael Flynn and Paul Manafort and Rick
gates Constantine killem killem Nick
killem Nick I never know how to
pronounce his last name 12 Russian
military intelligence officers 13
Russians and 3 Russian companies and
remember that Michael Cohen's indictment
was actually for a separate case not the
Moller investigation per se we're still
expecting indictments for Roger stone
and Jerome Corsi
possibly Donald Trump jr. and who knows
at this point how much further this will
go and it's really important to
understand that when this decision is
made by a judge to extend a grand jury
beyond 18 months they are looking at
whether the extension is in the interest
of the public and a judge looked at
everything and decided that despite the
fact that they've already had 18 months
of this grand jury it is indeed in the
public interest for the grand jury to be
extended and I am just shocked Pat that
Rudy Giuliani wasn't telling us the
truth when he said time and time again
that this thing was almost over yeah I
mean my rational mind says that this is
a good thing because it'll give Muller
more time and we can really get to the
bottom of what happened in 2016 and
potentially we'll see more indictments
because of it but on the other side I
kind of wanted to wrap up I want to see
what happened I want to hear what
Muller's findings are and I guess we'll
just have to be patient but by the time
six months is up that's gonna be two
full years of an investigation maybe the
country is getting tired of it well it's
not I mean here's the thing a politics
aside country getting tired and fatigued
aside this isn't shocking Watergate went
on for years this is a massive
undertaking you're looking at
criminality across multiple countries
across all levels of the organization
that was Donald Trump running for
president and you know every time that
we hear it's almost over we have to
remember wait a second how how would
anyone know that Muller has been running
one of the tightest ships no leaks
one of the most professionally run
investigations of its kind when we
actually learn
what's going on it's either because
number one there are court documents
filed which we can read or number two
judges or other parties confirm that
something happened like this grand jury
extension which was confirmed by the
judge every single supposedly cat
trumpets have pushed out about what's
about to happen has fallen flat because
molar is not taking any of this he's not
participating in this news and gossip
complex that so often pervades these
things when we found out that one of his
investigators was sending
inappropriately biased texts he that
individual was immediately dismissed
this is a Republican Special Counsel who
has run an airtight ship the Trump is
still want to defame and malign him and
I hope people are ready for 2019 because
it's going to be an absolutely massive
year politically today's program is
sponsored in part by zip recruiter you
know what is smart kicking off the new
year by planning out which rolls your
business needs to hire for you know what
else is smart starting the new year off
strong by going to zip recruiter dot-com
slash Pakman to actually hire the right
people for those jobs
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates for you it
has powerful matching technology which
scans thousands of resumes identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience and then it actively
invites them to apply to your job so
that you get qualified candidates fast
this is why zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the US this
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews and
right now my listeners and viewers can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman if you love our
show show your support to our show and
to zip recruiter by going to zip
recruiter dot-com slash PA que ma n
that's zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman zip recruiter is the smartest way
to hire